so we had the volar hearings today in
the Moller hearings we didn't get
anything new about what Donald Trump did
actions by Trump and the people around
him but we did get some on the record
confirmation from Robert Muller about
the obstructive goals and ambitions that
Donald Trump had in his actions now with
regard to impeachment after this is all
said and done after Robert Muller is
done testifying which is still happening
as of the taping of this segment
there will be people who say now it's
time for an impeachment inquiry there
will be some who will say now it's time
for the actual impeachment and removal
of Donald Trump from the White House
there will be others who will say let's
not impeach let's not even do the
inquiry question one is what will
Republicans think the answer is actually
who cares the important part is what do
Democrats think and there is this
growing problem of division within the
Democratic Party on the topic of
impeachment there are those in the
Democratic Party who are actually going
so far as to say not only should Trump
be impeached but there is evidence for a
conviction and removal on the basis of
that impeachment based on what we know
there are those in the Democratic Party
who say we should do an impeachment
inquiry and let the inquiry take us to
either impeaching or not impeaching but
let's start the inquiry right away and
then there are also Democrats who have
publicly said we shouldn't get involved
in this either for political reasons or
because they don't think that the
evidence we've seen so far justifies an
impeachment inquiry there is a movement
within the Democratic Party to do
nothing when it comes to impeachment or
an impeachment inquiry the bottom line
is that it's time for Democrats to cut
the crap and what I mean by that is that
if the infighting about impeachment if
the debate within the Democratic Party
about whether to even have an
impeachment inquiry continues much
longer it's going to get Trump
re-elected in 2020 as are other types of
Democratic infighting potentially as I
pointed out before there are three
options and Democrats should figure out
like today which one it is that they're
going to get behind it they need to
unite behind it and they need to carry
it out any
anything else is going to be damaging to
Democrats in 2020 both for the removal
of Donald Trump and also in many of
their own races option number one start
an impeachment inquiry right now you
don't go directly to impeachment you've
got to first do the inquiry I would
support the decision to start an
impeachment inquiry right now I think
there is more than enough evidence to
justify the inquiry starting right away
option two which I would also support
would be to decide we are going to table
this for now and start an impeachment
inquiry in six months or some number of
months in order to be more damaging to
Donald Trump's 2020 re-election campaign
it will become a distraction it will
interfere with Donald Trump's
campaigning I would support that yes as
I said on Monday I believe that it is
totally reasonable at this point in time
given the politics that have been played
by the other side on this issue I think
it would be completely reasonable to say
let's do the impeachment inquiry but
let's wait a little bit and time it so
as to be the most damaging to Donald
Trump as possible I would support that
as well
option number three would be to decide
today we are not going to pursue an
impeachment inquiry we are going to be
done with it and we are going to move on
a period I don't love it in the sense
that I think the evidence warrants an
impeachment inquiry and an impeachment
inquiry could be damaging to the
president in terms of his 2020
reelection chances but I would be okay
and I would still sort of get behind
I would accept the decision to say we
are not going to do anything with an
impeachment inquiry and we're going to
focus on the 2020 election what cannot
be an option is to continue infighting
for the rest of the 2020 campaign about
whether or not to do an impeachment
inquiry that is a loser's game Democrats
don't be losers you lose all the time we
continue to lose even though the
American public is as left as it has
ever been our elected officials continue
pulling pulling pulling to the right
yes partially because of voter
suppression partially because of
gerrymandering but also because of the
self-inflicted damage that Democrats do
there is a lot to gain with an
impeachment inquiry
which will push the content of the
Moller report into the mainstream there
is nothing to gain from just arguing
about whether or not to do the inquiry
it's been long enough if you still don't
think the inquiry is warranted based on
the facts
you're not going to six months from now
there's nothing else that will change
your mind
please stop the self-destructive stuff
and just decide and agree to stop the
public disagreements about it Moeller
has testified he's almost done with his
with his test
testimony you've got to decide on this
and move forward one way or the other
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube i've put a link in the
description i have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's B
Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma n